[Music]
hello
foreign
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
ah
hi everyone my name is karen miner
welcome to the table
and welcome to our good friday service
uh this evening
we are going to deviate a bit from our
normal
uh service outline and
we're going to focus on what good friday
is
which is reflecting on the moments that
led up
to christ's crucifixion on the cross
so you can expect a more reflective
contemplative service tonight
it can be so tempting to gloss over the
suffering and horrific death
that jesus endured on the cross so we
can get to
you know the happy part the easter part
the resurrection
but as christians we remember that god
is with us
especially and even in our suffering and
our pain
so as we linger on the crucifixion
tonight
we do so um bearing witness
and also holding hope and we can do that
with both hands we can hold those things
with both hands
so thank you for being with us tonight
and please join me
in this prayer that's by martin luther
merciful eternal god you did not
spare your own son but gave him up for
us all
to bear our sins on the cross
give our hearts such faith that we may
never be frightened
or despair through your son
jesus christ our lord
amen
hi my name is kirsten and i will be
reading john
19 1-5 then pilate took jesus and had
him flogged
the soldiers twisted together a crown of
thorns and put it on his head
they clothed him in a purple robe and
went up to him again and again saying
hail king of all the jews and slapped
him in the face
once more pilate came out and said to
the jews gathered up there
look i am bringing him out to you to let
you know that i find no basis for a
charge against him
when jesus came out wearing the crown of
thorns and the purple robe pilate said
to him
here is the man thank you
hi i'm dana and this is my wife karen
today we'll be reading for you
john chapter 19 verses 6 through 22.
as soon as the chief priests and their
officials saw him they shouted
crucify crucify but pilate answered
you take him and crucify him as for me i
find no basis for a charge against him
the jewish leaders insisted we have a
law and according to that law he must
die because he claimed to be the son of
god
when pilate heard this he was even more
afraid and he went back inside the
palace
where do you come from he asked jesus
but jesus gave him no answer
do you refuse to speak to me pilate said
don't you realize i have the power
either to free you or to crucify you
jesus answered you would have no power
over me if it were not given to you from
above
therefore the one who handed me over to
you is guilty of a greater sin
from then on on pilate tried to set
jesus free but the jewish leaders kept
shouting
if you let this man go you are no friend
of caesar anyone who
claims to be a king opposes caesar when
pilate heard this
he brought jesus out and sat down on the
judge's seat at a place known as the
stone pavement
which in aramaic is gabatha it was the
day of preparation of the passover
it was about noon here's your king
pilate said to the jews
but they shouted take him away take him
away
crucify him shall i crucify your king
pilate asked
we have no king but caesar the chief
priest answered
finally pilate handed him over to them
to be crucified
so the soldiers took charge of jesus
carrying his own cross
he went out to the place of the skull
which in aramaic is golgotha
there they crucified him and with him
two others one on each side and jesus in
the middle
pilate had a notice prepared and
fastened to the cross
it read jesus of nazareth the king of
the jews
many of the jews read this sign for the
place where jesus was crucified was near
the city
and the sign was written in aramaic
latin
and greek the chief priests of the jews
protested to pilate do not write the
king of the jews
but that this man claimed to be the king
of the jews
pilate answered what i have written
i have written thank you
[Music]
hmm
right
[Music]
jesus washes me
what is
[Music]
the great i am
who takes away
my sins
jesus washes me
all the blood of jesus
shed for me
what a sacrifice
that saved my
[Music]
it is
the precious
[Applause]
[Music]
it is my victory
oh what a love
no greater love
grace how can it be
[Music]
that in my sin
yes even then
he shed his blood
for me all the blood of jesus
washes me
[Music]
that saved my life
is the blood it is
my victory
[Music]
hello my name is jeremiah i'll be
reading to you from john chapter 19
verses 23 through 30. when the soldiers
crucified jesus they took his clothes
dividing them into four shares one for
each of them with the undergarment
remaining
this garment was seamless woven in one
piece from top to bottom
let's not tear it they said to one
another let's decide by a lot who will
get it
this happened that the scripture might
be filled that's it
they divided my clothes among them and
cast lots from my garden
so this is what the soldier did near the
cross jesus stood his mother
his mother's sister mary the wife of
clopas and mary magdalene
when jesus saw his mother there and the
disciple whom he loved standing nearby
he said to her
here's your son and to the disciple
here is your mother from that time on
this disciple took
her into his home later knowing that
everything had now been finished
and so that the scripture would be
fulfilled jesus said i am thirsty
a jar of wine and vinegar was there so
they soaked a sponge in it put the
sponge on the stock of the hyssop plant
and lifted it to jesus lips
when he received the drink jesus said it
is finished
with that he bowed his head and gave up
his spirit
[Music]
when i
and
[Music]
his head
[Applause]
[Music]
is
comes
[Music]
oh
bless your name
[Music]
so deep
my
[Music]
find that i'm
oh
[Music]
until the wonderful crowds
bless your name
[Music]
hello table family my name is stephanie
karasik
today i'm going to be reading from the
new international version
hebrews chapter 7 verses 22
and 27-28
because of this oath jesus has become
the guarantor of a better covenant
unlike the other high priests he does
not need to offer sacrifices day after
day
first for his own sins and then for the
sins of the people
he sacrificed for their sins once for
all when he offered himself
for the law appoints as high priests men
in all their weakness but the oath which
came after the law
appointed the son who has been made
perfect forever
[Music]
oh
the songs we've left
[Music]
oh the dreams we haven't seen
on the lord of mines
[Music]
chasing down
reaching out foreign
[Music]
is
foreign
[Music]
is
i had a dream that i finally
saw your face
dancing in the arms
dancing
[Music]
oh
where all of the streets down
[Music]
oh how i long for heaven
in
table family thank you for being with us
this evening uh so the title
of my message this good friday is
stuck stuck and
uh we have kind of already read our main
texts for tonight
um the hebrew seven passage that
stephanie read earlier and uh
and then all of john 19. um however i
would like us to begin just by focusing
on on just
one verse um this is one that jeremiah
read this is john 19
verse 30 and it says so when jesus
had received the sour wine he said
it is finished
it is finished and bowing his head
he gave up his spirit
so those three words spoken by jesus
that that i just read
they're they're so tiny and yet i
believe they carry
a certain depth a mountain of meaning
within them
because when jesus says it is finished
he is not simply saying my time has come
to pass away
rather jesus is proclaiming
that the high point the pinnacle of his
ministry
to bear our sins has been completed
and it's interesting that in more modern
times
uh we people in general we've kind of
become somewhat uncomfortable with this
idea
of j of jesus bearing our sins but i
i think that's that's a mistake because
as i look um both around me at the
broader culture
as well as within myself
it seems that we still
just just so desperately need
someone to do precisely that
uh let's talk first about the the
broader culture as we kind of look
around us
so the levels of resentment
that we are now bearing towards one
another
are absolutely astounding i i don't know
for sure i
suspect social media has kind of
amplified this and made it worse
regardless though of the exact um you
know path or how
it's happened it certainly feels like we
have reached peak levels of righteous
indignation with one another and to be
clear
like yes people um can be very crappy
and yes our history with one another
however you slice it whether along class
lines
racial lines gender sexual orientation
age
uh religion politics i mean what however
you slice it
uh it is in so many ways messy
and downright terrible at points so so i
get it
uh but the ways i i see us now kind of
blasting
anyone who disagrees with us as not
simply wrong or misguided but
as personally loathsome
and borderline less than human
or the way i see people collecting
offenses
like my grandmother collected precious
moments figurines
uh that's when you know like we've got
issues it's like
it's like where we're stuck
locked forever in an unending
conflict but as i said
it's not just what i've observed out
there in the culture that makes me think
jesus bearing sins
is a highly relevant idea it's also what
i've observed in myself
i find myself struggling all the time
with resentment does this demon so to
speak haunt you too
resentment this deep feeling that people
have done me
wrong and i can't get over it can't let
it go
sometimes it's from like silly kind of
embarrassing things
uh because you know to live in community
with others can be death by a thousand
paper cuts
other times it's more serious let me
start with a somewhat silly example i
have
three children and uh i live then with
uh four more of my my nieces and my
nephew so seven children total in our
home
and uh they all really like cutie
oranges
and uh they cutie oranges are now the
bane of my existence because if i have
to gather up
for the 1000th time the shell of another
dismembered cutie orange
simply left on the out the counter for
me
to throw out again i'm going to scream
at someone
uh okay so that's a silly example um
others though are
are more serious i remember um recently
i was out and around the town
uh i think i was at walmart or something
when suddenly i
saw someone across the store
and this was someone who had kind of
hurt me not like physically but but
relationally emotionally
and so i'm i'm going down uh one aisle
and when suddenly i saw them in like an
olympic
figure skater or a ballerina
executing a beautiful pirouette i just i
spun
just spun the other direction just just
going the other direction just flat out
avoiding
them uh and why did i do that well
because i thought i was over it
until i saw them and then i was like you
sorry no good so and so
my mind just exploded into argumentation
like internally it was just
what's going on i was stuck in
resentment
or sometimes i don't even have to be out
and around in fact nearly every time i'm
sitting in silence with with christ each
morning
almost inevitably at some point a face
flashes through my mind sometimes it
will be someone i interacted with
yesterday other times it's a person i
haven't thought about in a decade
but sure enough who is it it's
someone that i perceive did me wrong
and i can feel the anger welling
up inside me and then the mental
argumentation begins again
i become in that moment the unholy
trinity
of prosecuting attorney judge
and jury and i am blasting them
yes in this moment what i'm describing
i'm supposed to be praying but
when this happens it just takes over and
i'm just i'm blasting them with my
resentment
and bitterness just giving them what
they deserve
i'm stuck stuck in resentment
sometimes though it's not even about
other people just as often maybe more
often
it's myself all of my failures
flashing through my mind i can see
why people are afraid of silence i get
it like
because in silence it all comes back up
doesn't it that's why sometimes we're in
the car we have turn on the radio
you know we're at the house turn on the
tv just no one else's home just turn on
just get some noise
because when we're there just with
ourselves it all comes back
up doesn't it all of the anger and the
bitterness the unforgiveness the
unresolved conflict the regret the
tension and in that moment
it's like it's like we're having to
relive it in some sense it's just all
coming
back up heart racing my
hands getting cold it just feels
like i am stuck
and that's us right lost in a cycle
of collective and individual
resentment and bitterness and honestly
it feels like a dead end
because sometimes you can work it
through sometimes
that person who offended you know they
will say
they are sorry uh but often
they won't or sometimes we're just
fighting ghosts that died long ago
i mean there's no one even left for us
to either give an apology to
or receive an apology from
just a stalemate now
the old testament had a solution
of sorts specifically for your own
sins against others so what you do is
you would sacrifice
an animal and then you'd ask god to
extend forgiveness to you so the
sacrifice of an
animal it was a a physical act that
communicated
look this mattered sin has
consequences that's the symbol the
symbolism of it
it sin has consequences it breaks things
it breaks
creatures it breaks my sense of
communion and connectedness to god and
other people
and so the animal here was a symbol of
the weightiness
of that breaking but of course
because your sins weren't a one-time
thing
neither was your sacrificing and so
you kept going back to engage
the sacrificial ritual over and over
and over again but eventually
uh this led to a type of crisis
among the people of god at that time and
uh
prophets like micah and jeremiah and
isaiah they all began to say
this doesn't seem to be working
here's a a passage from the old
testament this is micah chapter six
verses six through
seven he writes with what shall i come
before the lord
and bow down before the exalted
god shall i come before him with burnt
offerings with calves
a year old will the lord be pleased with
thousands of rams with ten thousand
rivers of olive oil
shall i offer my firstborn for my
transgression
the fruit of my body for the sin of my
soul now just to be clear they didn't
actually practice
like human sacrifice but you can see him
kind of kind of trying to play it out
like what else can i do like
we're stuck can you hear the echoes
there of this
this doesn't seem to be working it's
it's like putting um
band-aids on a wound that actually needs
surgery you ever had that moment where
you cut yourself
and it's a deep one and you're trying to
decide
like whether or not to go to the
hospital for more serious treatment
but maybe you're hopeful so you kind of
you know you slap a band-aid on and you
like raise your arm
but the blood keeps running and
eventually
reality you know it sets in like we need
to go to the hospital
well and kind of take that metaphor uh
it took a few thousand years
but eventually for the people of god
reality set in the blood of
lambs and goats uh it was
was not cutting it we needed a deeper
covenant we needed a new high priest we
needed a
final sacrifice to get us unstuck
and this is the great theme of the book
of hebrews
in the new testament uh which is why it
says
in verse 27 of chapter seven as
stephanie earlier so beautifully read it
unlike the other high priests he jesus
has no need to offer sacrifices day
after day first for his own sins then
for those the people
now this he did once for all when he
offered who himself
or as jesus in john 19 verse 30 put it
it is finished
isn't it interesting how when we are
fighting with someone
uh but then something interrupts us we
will say uh this is not finished
have you ever said something like that
like don't you think that just because
i'm walking away to handle this other
situation
don't you think that this is finished
this is not finished i think that's a
beautiful picture of what's going on of
really of
us right we're sort of looking at the
whole world
and um and in the same way everyone's
kind of looking
back at us like we're all saying to one
another
this is not finished this is not
finished oh no you think this is
oh this is not finished no no no no no
this can you get the picture
everyone's just we are not finished
but seen from the cross
seen from the cross it actually
is finished
we already know where this ends it ends
with god
miracle of miracles extending the
possibility of forgiveness and healing
to
every person to every tribe in nation
and tongue it is
finished now
you might say but what about what about
justice
i mean if god just forgives everyone
are we just throwing justice to the wind
that's a good question
um for one thing i mean this is why
jesus died
right to be the scapegoat but but even
beyond that i've preached on this before
that
i actually do believe in in some sort of
kind of afterlife
um judgment uh commonly known as hell as
un
understood but when i say that i mean it
um hell as understood as the purifying
fire of the love
of god and so if someone does not repent
and change
then perhaps what they have done has so
deeply marred and mangled their soul in
the life to come
that they will experience the love of
god as a
purifying fire as a a wounding
love that is actually healing them
but but it it's uncomfortable
so now the key is though in that vision
god does not hate them
and christ does not withhold forgiveness
from them he died for them
and yes again you you might be thinking
like what about
what about reconciliation like are you
saying i'm just we're just everyone hold
hands
just be friends and um again
forgiveness is it's not it's not the
same as reconciliation
you can't reconcile much less trust
someone in this life who won't own their
mess
right their own stuff their own sins so
of course
you may still have to set healthy
boundaries with people who are abusive
to you
um or just plain immature and unwilling
to own their stuff
and yes there is a season for you to
grieve
and feel all the feelings and um
you know go to therapy or join a small
group
uh and work things through and i don't
believe churches
are places that or should be places that
like rush people to quickly forgive
you know those who have deeply wounded
them so yes
um all of those objections have truth in
them
no doubt but
what are we tempted by it seems in this
age
that as we have let go of this
idea of jesus bearing sins
as we have let go even of the idea of
forgiveness
that we are in that very moment we are
tempted by a
deep pride a pride that says
i am innocent and i would
never do the things they
have done i am not capable of
that level of evil but you know what
that is
that's ego we are so very fragile that
we
we do not want to face the fact that we
are
all capable of atrocious
things our culture is so deeply immature
we have not yet learned to face
our shadow side to recognize it
to realize that the root of that same
evil is in us too
because god knows god knows
about the addiction god knows about
the abuse not that you suffered that you
inflicted
on others god knows about the adultery
the ten thousand lies god knows whatever
your secret
messed upness is and when we
acknowledge that
only then have we started
down the spiritual path only then
have we begun to be a christian
because now you can humble yourself
now you can join all of the other
sinners
at the foot of the cross and we can look
up and we can say that was
my doing that was our
doing he is bearing not their sins he is
bearing
my sins and our sins it
is finished for them
and for me and this is why
to be a christian is to be on the path
of becoming unstuck
this is why it is the highest freedom
it is to live into the knowledge
that i am fully forgiven and
deeply loved and thus i am free
to humble myself to receive that
forgiveness and then do what
extend it to others extend it to others
does this mean we will always get that
right um no
does it mean i will always see that
person in walmart and run up and greet
them warmly
no but i'm learning
we are learning to get unstuck
from our bitterness our resentment
our rage because it
is finished
so in closing i guess the question
would be where are you still
stuck and are
you ready to declare that it
is finished if so i want
i want to just invite you to pray
this prayer along with me lord jesus
i know that you bore my sin
on the cross and that means
you bore their sin
too forgive me
as i forgive them release
me as i release them
help me live in a way that is light
and free from all resentment
in the name of the crucified one i pray
amen
you need not say goodbye
the people will shout my name
pilate will tell them there's nothing
i've done to deserve this
but they will refuse pilate will stand
me beside barabbas
a murderer and they will choose him
over me pilate will appeal to the priest
insist on simply whipping me to appease
their fury
but they will shout it louder crucify
crucify
but still you may not say
goodbye my hands will be tied to a post
the sound of the whip will ring in your
ears and in your chest
the soldiers will peel the skin off my
back a ring of thorny branches will be
pressed into my scalp until the blood
runs into my eyes oh
but listen you need not say
goodbye i will carry that cross
i will go to the place of the skull and
there they will drive the iron stakes
between the bones in my wrist
with a hammer that will nail my feet
into the tree
i will be raised up as the world
waits for me to die
nevertheless you need not say
goodbye between two thieves i will hang
you may hear me speaking to my father
your father
you may hear me ask him why
but child you may not say
goodbye
what you won't see what you won't hear
what you won't know until all of this is
done is that in
that moment i was paying the penalty of
your wrongdoing every wrongdoing every
mistake
every act of envy every word of hatred
every moment of violence and greed and
spite
every selfish desire every lustful
thought
every moment of weakness and weariness
all the failures of human history
will be in my hands and on my head
on that cross i will suffer the rat that
was
destined for you every guilty verdict
fallen on me
your punishment will be paid for in my
blood and it
will be enough i will die
on your cross i will let out a final
sigh
know that i have loved you
and you need not goodbye but if
you must if you
absolutely must say the word goodbye
then say it like this
good bye fear
goodbye sorry goodbye
rejection goodbye shane
say it like this goodbye guilt goodbye
condemnation goodbye all the regrets of
the past
look up at the cross speak the words
goodbye
addiction goodbye chains goodbye
hopelessness right here in this place
say it aloud goodbye captivity hello
freedom goodbye loneliness below
belonging
goodbye defeat hello victory
this is the end of the curse this is the
demise of the serpent
this is all debts paid this is
it is finished goodbye
all the powers of hell goodbye darkness
goodbye dread
goodbye every sin go ahead and say
good bye death
speak
be free
but don't say goodbye to me
yes you'll see them put the spear in my
side
but remember it's only friday
so you need not say
[Music]
goodbye
our benediction tonight was written by
padraig
otama and it's entitled go in pieces
the task is ended go in pieces
our concluding faith is being rear-ended
certainties being amended and
something's getting mended
that we didn't know was torn we're
unraveling
and are traveling to a place of new
formed patterns
with delusion as a fusion of loss
and hope and pain and beauty
so the task is ended
go in pieces to see
and feel your world
thanks so much for joining us tonight
we hope to see you sunday morning for
our easter service
at 10 30 a.m outdoors at garland city
square
and we'll also be streaming it online
so go in peace and in pieces
good night
you